this is a production of Cornell
University hello everyone my name is
keny Rodriguez I am a PhD student at
Cornell University and today I'm with
Steve reers he's a Horticulture
specialist and today we'll talk about
some pests that can be in our Gardens so
Steve um we know that there are some
pests or diseases that can affect our
fields or our vegetable gardens and we
would like to know what is a common P
that we will see and what what what are
things that we can recognize to know
what it is and maybe a a control that we
can use to do that so I guess the first
one we're going to be talking about
today is squash Vine bore and that's a
huge problem for home gardeners if
you're growing zucchini you're probably
going to have squash Vine B and so I
show this plant right now so this is a a
plant that we had and I've just pulled
it up so this we just cut it right at
the base of the plant here and this is I
don't though I don't see any right here
this is where squash Vine bores
typically lay their eggs and what will
happen is the eggs will be laid usually
within about 2 to three inches of where
it goes into the soil the eggs will
hatch and as soon as they hatch they
will go inside the stem and then that's
the perfect place for them and what
they'll do is they'll just start feeding
inside the stem and then they will start
eating and and pushing their frass out
behind them and you'll always be able to
tell because you'll see some small holes
and this will just be starting to rot
and they'll be all this insect frass
that's coming out um eventually the
plant will start to wilt eventually it
will ey and again that can be a real
problem and something that more so
probably home gardeners have a problem
with than commercial
Growers and what we can do to control
that or like um is there another way
that we can use to manage this for for a
home Gardener um it's a little bit more
work but again since the insect it's
laying its eggs right here uh and it's
not typically laying its eggs further up
on the plant what you can do is you can
wrap that stem and people have wrapped
aluminum foil around it I've seen people
wrap like old panty hose around it um if
you have a floating row cover you could
take a little strip of that and wrap
that around it and again it only has to
be up to about those 3 in and that will
prevent the insect if it's as it's
flying and it's a it's a moth most
people don't really see it but I think
you'll show a picture of it later it's a
moth that flies during the daytime hours
um and will be laying its eggs here uh
so again if you wrap the stem that can
help there's also another method that's
approved would be to use um you could
use a spray it's called a Diel spray
which is a bacterial material um it's
approved for organic farming and organic
gardening and again if you could spray
that maybe every 5 to 7 Days uh just
right here at the base and again what
will happen is as soon as those eggs
hatch before they can get into the stem
they start eating and they'll eat this
bacteria and again it's naturally
derived from soil uh bacteria and that
will kill them so that's another thing
that you can do you could also cover the
entire plot with with a row cover
typically we won't see Vine Wars around
here until mid June or so and then they
will usually we only have one generation
so the moths the adult moths will be
active on from mid June until usually
the end of July after that they're done
um so again a late planting of zucchini
which only takes about 60 days if you
plant it about the first week of August
you can also get around the season of it
as well okay a really important thing
with squash Vine b as well is once
you're done with your zucchini plants
even if it's wilted if it has the squash
Vine pull them out of the garden compost
them if you can find the the worms
themselves the caterpillars pull those
out because they will overwinter in the
soil and then they're just going to be a
problem next next spring for you as well
so again you want to make sure that you
pull up that all those old curbit plants
that you have out there that'll help
really to to help control it for the
following year too learn about squash
bite but and this is a good time for us
to know what to do whenever we have this
problem thank you so much for your
advises and I know that this will be
very helpful for people that is
harvesting or it's having their squash
plants or their zucchini plants in their
fields or in a garden this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell.edu